un drôle d'anniversaire de pour votre
organisme que deux factrices en
confinement évidemment on ne dira
reporté les festivités qu'on imaginait
donc on profite de l'année du début de
l'année 2000 vainqueur souligné de en
mode virtuel dans nos évènements en mode
virtuel notre vingtième anniversaire
alors justement dès la naissance de la
fondation parce que donc 20e
anniversaire ses 20 ans que vous
travaillez donc nous commun et l'aîné
c'est de cette fondation c'est que
c'était quoi les objectifs en premier
est ce que ces objectifs ont changé
ça vient d'une personne en fait il
s'appelle laurent mccutcheon un grand
militant qui malheureusement décédé en
le rhum et etienne était président de
gai écoute la ligne d'écouté qui
maintenant interlining et à partir de ce
que on entendait sur la ligne d'écouté
est venue l'idée de en plus d'offrir de
la psycho social de changer les
mentalités au niveau sociétal donc leur
à ma question c'est du belge veut créer
un organisme qui veut développer des
campagnes développer des outils des
programmes pour changer les mentalités
pour que ce soit plus en plus et faveur
des personnes je vais dq plus donc d'où
l'idée de créer la fondation émergence
notamment avec son programme central qui
est la journée internationale contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie qui a lu
le 7 mai donc c'est la fondation
émergence que crée cette journée leur
pour la première fois au monde en 2003
dans trois ans après la création de
l'organisme et qui est maintenant
souligné non plus d'une trentaine de
pays
donc c'est un petit peu le le contexte
dans lequel le ram est question de viser
vraiment à faire avancer
la cause une bosse et talent par les
droits par le changement des mentalités
par plus d'intrusion et vous dit
exactement les mots que je voulais
amener le changement des mentalités
parce que à 20 ans j'imagine j'ose
imaginer que beaucoup de choses ont
changé mais dans la pratique est ce que
vous diriez que les mentalités la
sensibilisation de la population en ce
qui concerne les réalités les défis de
la pluralité d'identité donc est ce que
ça change vraiment c'est ce qui reste
toujours du travail à faire surtout pour
les réalités trans et non binaire par
contre il est vrai que sur le long terme
en marquant même une certaine évolution
une certain certains progrès au niveau
des de l'inclusion
je dirais que le le gros changement
c'est qu'avant on parlait surtout
d'acceptation de tolérance c'était
principalement le vocabulaire qu'on
l'utilisait aujourd'hui on a plutôt
d'inclusion donc on veut seulement être
toléré comme comme personne juridique
plus mais vraiment être inclus dans la
société dans toutes les sphères de dans
tous les domaines de la société que ce
soit au travail que ce soit à l'école
dans les familles que ça soit aussi dans
les résidences pour aînés
nous on ne programme pour que vieillir
soit gai qui existe maintenant depuis
dix ans et qui vise vraiment à plus d'un
client dans le milieu rennais mieux
énormément de travail à faire mais c'est
vrai que sur l'ensemble il ya quand même
eu de beauzac il par exemple la jouer
de l'identité l'expression de genre
comme motif de discrimination dans
l'achat ça me permet d'avoir un levier
pour lutter contre les zones ce cri
nation au niveau législatif et d'ouvrir
la discussion au niveau collectif c'est
l'horreur sur l'inclusion de l'ensemble
du personnel j'ai des pulsions foot ici
que healy à certaines réalités certaine
identité sexuelle qui sont plus seuls
mieux compris et d'autre pourquoi vous
pensez qu'il ya certaines certaine
identité sexuelle qui sont facilement
compris peut-être que ça fait plus de
temps colin pas j'essaie de voir quels
aspects pourraient déterminer ce qui
concerne la compréhension de toutes les
diversités sexuelle est une excellente
question j'aurais un peu de difficulté à
y répondre exactement à ce que je peux
dire si je pense que dans l'organisation
même des groupes de défense des droits
il ya des enjeux qui ce niveau on irait
en niveau 2 e étape par étape
le ski le plus facile à modifier ce qui
aussi selon les opportunités qui
tranquillement ont fait changer les lois
et aussi des sujets qu'on peut aborder
plus difficilement au niveau du grand
public et des sujets qui sont plus
faciles à mettre de l'avant
donc c'est sûr que dans les stratégies
de sensibilisation et des priorisations
une priorisation qu'il faut faire donc
je dirais que c'est sûr que sur le très
long terme
les gays et lesbiennes ont été le groupe
qui a été le plus mis de l'avant
ça veut pas dire que les groupes france
nos mineurs n existait pas aux contrats
sont toujours été présent mais vu qu'ils
subissent plus de discrimination il
fallait comme brisé d'abord des barea
plus large pour ensuite aider et aider
ces communautés leur parlons maintenant
des célébrations de cette vingtième
anniversaire
donc vous dites là il y avait des choses
qui ont dû être modifiées et a donné la
pandémie et tout le monde 1 800 800 à
toulon
faire de notre vie donc dit non puisque
vous allez faire comment vous allez
célébrer que sont les principaux
événements qui vont avoir lieu première
des choses c'est sûr qu'on est quand
même un peu limité avec le confinement
on aimerait bien faire des feux
d'artifice et mais je pense que
l'important pour nous c'est moins le
côté festif que de toujours rappeler que
le travail reste à faire que des
avancées évidemment au cours des vingt
dernières années même plus mais qui
reste encore beaucoup de travail à faire
nous c'est pour ce que nous on appelle
on profite du 20e anniversaire va les
chercher des fonds pour nous permettre
de développer de nouveaux programmes
pérenniser nos programmes actuels que ça
soit la journée internationale contre
l'homophobie et la transphobie
on sait que au québec beaucoup de choses
à faire mais à l'international et encore
70 qui criminalisent l'homosexualité udd
qui font la peine de mort pour les
personnages habités donc on a besoin
livres de fonds pour aller changer les
mentalités même à l'international
on ne le programme pour que vieillir
soit gai donc comme je mentionnais tout
à l'heure pour les résidences personnes
aînées on est le programme pro alliés
pour le milieu de travail c'est quand
même au canada
plus d'une personne sur deux est âgé bt
qui est dans le placard par rapport à
son supérieur par rapport aux collègues
donc on se croirait dans un pays où est
franchement l'inclusion du travail est
acquise alors que c'est pas du tout le
cas
mais vraiment vraiment donc voilà c'est
sur du personnel
oui c'est ça se passe exactement sur ses
53 54% des répondants sur mes cinq sens
répond d'un prêt
c'est fait alors oui effectivement c'est
presque pas l'un des gens qui veulent
pas nuire à leur carrière veulent
possible non plus de mauvaise blague non
plus subir de discrimination expire
exhibe puis moi je les comprends parce
que dieu les milieux de travail c'est
très compétitif
souvent on utilise le mot phobie la
transphobie pau pour se faire valoir
pour monter pour avoir une promotion
donc de toutes sortes d'enjeux al
internes qui peuvent nuire aux personnes
lgbt qui plus est donc très fermes pour
parler de leur orientation sexuelle ça
nous démontre à quel point c'est
vraiment pas la même chose pour d'autres
identités sexuelles en étant
hétérosexuels on on en parle ouvertement
on n'a pas une questionnement si c'est
pertinent au nom de l'aider un public et
un nom à nos patrons exactement en fait
c'est comment on dit souvent les
personnes hétérosexuelles font leur
coming out sans le savoir par exemple au
dîner quand on tarde notre cinq semaines
sont enjoués ses enfants c'est un coming
out d'une certaine manière
donc les personnes lgbt sont pas
toujours à reste de mentionner donc cela
ils vont se créer une double vie double
identité
juste pour ne pas être achats les
patrons békés question donc
effectivement réussi 17 ans j'ai là où
on parle de notre sexualité de au sens
très large de vie amoureuse de vie
romantique souvent sans même s'en
apercevoir
c'est quand on est dans un groupe
minoritaire on se rend compte que tout
les trucs qui vont de soi en fait ne
sont pas nécessairement pour tout le
monde laurent brault dites nous quelle
est l'adresse à laquelle les gens
doivent se référer s'ils veulent avoir
plus d'informations sur les événements
sur les routes ça laisse événements que
vous avez gagné c'est dans la marche de
cette vingtième anniversaire
donc il faut se rend sur un autre site
web de w
wwf fondation émergence points quand
vous avez accès à l'actualité de nos
activités de nos programmes si le lien à
neutre en quinze oeuvres d'art vous
pouvez aussi suivre tout ce qu'on fait
sur notre page facebook de la fondation
émergence
on est en train de produire une vidéo
20e anniversaire qui va être lancée dans
dans quelques semaines et une remise de
plis également de remise de prix
annuelle pour la journée internationale
contre l'homophobie et la transphobie
sera un moment important pour mentionner
notre vingtième anniversaire
laurent brault bousaid directeur général
de la fondation émergence merci beaucoup
ça fait plaisir merci l'invitation
[Musique]